head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard
charts Hunter Biden claims he might flee
the country if Donald Trump is elected
president so pick your poison ladies and
gentlemen look I'm going to say it Luke
I'm going to say it mm Civil War D what
about it take a shot you've got right
now journalists being arrested the
expectation and the evidence is clear
that more journalists more personalities
they're going to keep arresting people
over January 6 that is their move in the
inverse Hunter Biden feels he has to
flee the country if Trump is elected
because if Trump is elected the
expectation is he is going to start
arresting these criminally corrupt
individuals no matter which way you cut
it neither side can accept defeat in
2024 no matter matter what I mean while
cohesion is a win well you got to
understand Ian the Democrats embarked on
a trajectory that there's no going back
from with this legal lawfare that they
have utilized against the Republicans uh
you you look at everything that they
have been doing it has opened up a
Pandora's Box that we see in many
developing nations we see in banana
republics the same kind of behavior
going after politicians going after
lawyers going after journalists because
of their political ideas and expressions
that is a very dangerous move that
there's no going back from now if there
is a transition of power and I and I say
that very carefully if there is a
transition of power why wouldn't the
next president of the United States who
is a republican use the same kind of
legal lawfare that the Democrats used
and they would be at a disadvantage now
if they didn't because they would show
weakness and they would allow them to
get away with essentially this larger
pendulum swing escalation that sadly uh
there's no going back from I feel like
they have everything to lose obviously
Joe Biden has everything to lose which
is why he's probably still running to
protect himself because they've
committed so many crimes with the
political persecution of course and you
know the January 6 first select unselect
committee uh was so Lawless and all of
the stuff that will be uncovered
obviously if Trump gets back in and
hopefully he would actually persecute
these people because they have committed
real crimes unlike you know Donald Trump
I don't think he's committed real crimes
and I'm not
being uh biased towards Trump but he
hasn't so I think that the Democrats
have everything to lose and they're
going to pull out all the stops to win
next next year whatever that means
they're going to pull out all the stops
I had this uh I think a lot of
presidents uh violate the laws and do
something illegal but uh they're never
held accountable for it I I would kind
of disagree with you on that point but
the fact that they are Prosecuting it
for the first time um shows the clear
escalation cuz there's previous
presidents that murdered and
assassinated American teenage citizens
uh with their own signatures with their
own with the with them personally
signing off on it so all presid
presidents essentially in my book are
criminals and they have committed
criminal violations against human beings
against innocent crime I mean I guess
how could you say that minus war crimes
because war crimes are terrible I guess
like in the eyes of any other Nation
American Presidents commit genocide
commit many war crimes but I don't think
anyone's really been as bad as Joe Biden
when it comes to the political
persecution that's going on in America
right now and the attack of a political
opponent and his supporters and his
attorneys and anybody that voted for
Trump is automatically An Enemy of the
State absolutely no of course you're
absolutely right about that and and
that's the point that we're making here
Ian you were going to say something well
I was going to say a couple things one
is I think if another president comes in
and they're like the pendulum swinging
like slow it down we can do this
together cuz if we fall in the disarray
the whole world's going to create World
War 3 on our soil it's going to be the
roads will get like it would be like
infection starvation and dehydration are
the three main enemies not weapons and
bombs if if that happens we cannot let
that happen we got to stay together but
I had this Vision like 3 or 4 days ago
where I was like saw the government
actually like really going and rounding
people up kind of like arresting sort of
like I mean you could kind of consider
what this this this journalist and
everything and that people cheering it
on like that's like like how they create
like a like a um a scapegoat a group of
scapegoats and then the rest of the
people are like yeah and then I started
thinking of the Nazis and how they did
that to the Jews and I'm like just wake
up wake up people wake up it's so scary
and like I always feel like whenever I
see a a group being um demonized I'm
always very suspicious like for example
with January 6 how the white male that
that's like the kind of like the
midwestern really white guy became a
terrorist a domestic terrorists there's
a reason it's like the same thing that
happened after I think the Iraq War how
Muslim people were really demonized and
that's what ushered in The Patriot Act
January s six and demonizing white men
ushered in this really tyrannical stuff
and this judicial precedent that nobody
has any idea what the long-term
ramifications will be so I'm always
suspicious when a group is demonized by
the media and by the Deep State let's go
back to this story cuz I you know if
this story is true if the sources are
true here Hunter is not wrong like if
Donald Trump's becomes president of the
United States if you're looking to to
save your own kind of self your own skin
get the hell out of Dodge what if and
what if uh Trump loses and what if it's
Nome Nome Harris or Nome Whitmer I mean
if it's Whitmer this lady is a psychotic
and deranged murderer right uh what did
why did you say that the putting covid
patients into oh oh my favorite Story
the dude who mercilessly beat that old
man to death in a Michigan nursing home
remember that one no I don't think so
pull it up no a lot of people are saying
that Whitmer could be the VP for Nome um
that could be a likely candidacy that uh
would be absolutely atrocious for the
American people 20-year-old beating
suspect was moved to nursing home
because he has covid-19 says father
Detroit so like uh many states these
governors were putting people who should
not be in nursing homes and nursing
homes during Co and it resulted and New
York is the is the example we all know
15,000 dead and that was Andrew CUO so
that's why people are like you think
Chris CUO would come on the show no he
would never come on the show because I
got to say I'm sorry I'm probably the
only one with the balls to say to Chris
comomo your brother is a mass murderer
who murdered 15,000 people including a
friend of the show whose parents died
because of what Andrew KO did I think we
got to start manifesting that these
people will come on the show because
that's the culture or if if they won't
if people refuse to talk then we lose
the C that's the loss that's game over
if we if people refuse to communicate
it's game over sociopathic Mass
murderers uh don't usually deal with a
confrontation well they don't deal with
being confronted on their horrible
actions that have led to tremendous
human life loss uh especially when
called out directly to it face to face I
called out a lot of war criminals
personally myself during my journalistic
career uh they don't get happy they they
I got arrested a number of times for
confronting a lot of politicians about
their very horrible ilicit actions they
get mad they freak out yeah right and in
New York right now speaking of there's a
new law that they just passed that
quarantine camps like if you're sick or
if you're unvaccinated literally this is
something that Kathy hokel put through
you could be put in a quarantine Camp
against your uh against your will so
they could come to your home knock on
the door pull you out and throw you in a
quarantine Camp so we we we we talk
about Hunter Biden you know wanting to
get out get out of Dodge but then what's
the uh
what if what if Trump loses now here's
what I think do we get out of Dodge well
I don't think uh I don't think Trump
wins or loses I don't think Biden
Newsome whoever it's going to be wins or
loses I don't think I I I I cannot see a
reasonable conclusion to the election I
can't in 2020 we had a lawsuit Texas V
Pennsylvania with I believe 48 states
that were involved in the suit either
joining in or fi filing uh uh amicus
briefs or what's what's the proper
plural Amai or whatever I don't know the
point is they're all basically saying we
we we we are we are pushing back the
only reason it stopped there was because
the Supreme Court refused to take the
case and the case fizzled which was the
Supreme Court taking sides taking sides
with Pennsylvania right this left a very
sour taste in the mouths of States like
Texas and Texas that Ken Paxton goes
hard and you you've got you got Missouri
as well going after these
fraudsters what's going to happen at the
end of 24 before we even get to election
day there's going to be legal challenges
to early voting there's going to be
claims of widespread fraud on both sides
the election will happen different
channels and different Outlets will
report different data people are going
to people are people are going to notice
like oh look the number changed on the
TV it went up then it went down and no
one will accept it because I'll tell you
nobody accepted 2016 the Democrats said
it was Russia the Democrats actually
believe beli that Russia hacked the
machines in 2020 it was the
conservatives who said the Democrats
rigged the machines 2024 is going to be
we will not accept this why because the
Biden doj is already weaponizing law
enforcement to arrest innocent people
like this journalist Steve Baker that's
already happening so you've got all of
these Trump Administration officials
facing criminal prosecution and they're
like Trump needs to win we have to win
this one now many of them are bowing out
like cowards that that's true but a lot
of people are like if Trump does not win
this is life or death hunter Biden
saying the same thing so it's going to
be 100,000 lawsuits from the left
100,000 from the right the courts are
going to be jammed up and I imagine come
December we don't know who won I just
don't want to rest everything on one
guy's status as president like it it's
so much about the individual loving the
the humans around them and and
sacrificing themselves for the humans
around
them I I I agree with you but for the J
Sixers it is life or death it for many
of them uh especially with a lot of them
that are in solitary confinement so I
agree with your sentiment never put any
man above yourself never worship any man
never Idol any man or or woman always
make sure to take care of yourself first
I think the bigger solution other than
voting is you being the best version of
yourself being happy being healthy being
strong being financially successful
that's the way out of this us realizing
hey we don't need government we don't
need tyranny we don't need all this
other all around us that they keep
trying to sell us and only works because
we keep buying it so so I understand
that that sentiment a lot but sadly with
how weaponized the political system has
become it is life or death for a lot of
individuals it is freedom or slavery for
a lot of individuals and that's those
are high stakes right there and and and
the future of this country as well to
where it is going to be going from here
I'm concerned that Donald Trump's Don
I'm going to call you is like does he
not realize that like if he keeps
pushing and being like I'm going to go
get I'm going to get that like it's
making it worse for people like the
people that are in prison it's making it
worse it's making them be like oh we
need less Trump supports cuz he keeps
saying he's going to come destroy like
why doesn't he tone down and start to
talk about
Unity yeah that's always the mysterious
question why Donald Trump says some of
the things he does I guess like you know
he says some things that are really out
there um I think a lot of the times he's
just saying it kind of jokingly like he
said I'm going to come after these
people but only on day one and you know
he didn't say that he he said that or he
didn't he said on day one I'm going to
baby drill and build a wall he dodged
the question okay Hannity said are you
going to be a dictator and go after
these people and Trump said only on day
one we're going to build a wall and
we're going to drill so I guess see even
I am I I am uh guilty of hearing fake
news because that was what I heard he
said it he said when he said are you
going to be a dictator and do this he
said only on day one that was his answer
and then he went on to say I'm going to
drill C off and they used that sound
everywhere that's what I'm saying that's
why I was under that impression and they
and they use these clever lines where
Trump says he will he will be dictator
only one day right and I I believed it I
believe I said I he said it but he was
probably joking around you know that's
what I thought I thought it was such a
lazy way to answer the question no I
don't think he wasn't listening he was
not listen that's a lazy way to answer
like not listening say I didn't hear I
didn't understand what you said please
repeat the question handy was asking are
you going to use your powers to get
revenge and retribution and Trump's not
paying attention and then he just hears
dictator he goes yes to build a wall and
then kenned goes no that's not what I
asked I asked about retribution and
Trump's like we're going to drill and so
you can argue that Trump just did not
answer the question that's the most
reasonable
explanation that's it he didn't actually
answer the question about whether he'd
really be a dictator to get revenge he
answered it he just but it look why does
Donald Trump say the things he's saying
well you know I kind of feel like a lot
of people in this country think that
when the doj is weaponized when the
farle is given cart blanch you have to
actually fight back and how do you do it
Donald Trump talking is probably the
best way to do it why well we don't want
violence we don't want Civil War so a
lot of people are like we're going to be
reasonable we're not going to Rite we're
not going to do it black Liv matter does
we are going to vote in local uh
election officials which they've done
we're going to vote in populist
candidates in Congress which they've
done in many areas and we're going to
support Donald Trump then Donald Trump
says I'm going to go after him and I'm
going to do all this but here's the
thing that's the best possible way to
actually do it to vote for Trump and
then hope he uses law enforcement powers
to arrest criminals you could consider
that as a tactic but I think better ways
to strengthen our economy I think that
the best way to to to solve the
corruptive issue is to make a stronger
base growth domestic product grow on how
do you do that when for the past 20
years they've extracted the GDP and
sended to China you need to I think it's
hydrogen fuel you need to alter our fuel
you you didn't answer my question well
um you need to start pumping hydrogen
through the methane systems what does
that have to do with them sending our
manufacturing base to China how do we
make hydrogen when we don't have people
here to work factories or factories that
can do hydrogen refiner uh refining we
have some at a Rice University they're
hitting carbon trash with electricity at
7,000 de with flash jeel Heating and
turning it into hydrogen fuel so let's
go back to the beginning what should the
American people do when for the past 20
years the neocons and neolibs have sent
our manufacturing base to China build
new manufacturing and how do you do that
by inspiring people show them what to
build who does that a regular American
what can they what can they do you can
uh search uh James tour out of Rice
University and look at what they're
doing with creating High I got I got I
got a problem for you though there's an
EPA regulation barring the construction
of a factories and the carbon emissions
in this area it doesn't produce carbon
emissions I'm not talking about hydrogen
specifically I'm talking about the
manufacturing base explain what you just
said the reason people voted for Donald
Trump is because he vowed to relax rules
executive orders and to work with
Congress to repeal laws to allow
manufacturing to return to this country
that's not the only reason that's a big
component what we end up seeing in the
first first ter of Donald Trump was a $3
billion reinvestment into Michigan from
autom manufacturers who brought their
factories back the reason why Trump
wanted to remove environmental
regulations like the EPA was because
this was the reason why these factories
moved in the first place they could not
actually produce things and the
Democrats they've done the perfect
perfect system of no tariffs free trade
and high regulation high taxes the
trifecta what that means is anybody who
wants to open a factory say to make
socks they're like socks produced much
carbon EPA says no taxes are at 35% we
can't afford it however free trade with
China that means we put our Factory in
China we pump out as much carbon as we
want the socks get sent back to the US
for free and the US taxpayer dollars and
wages get sent to China instead thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a
member over at
timcast.net
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time